50 feet from syria i
i would love to talk at least a little
bit about this film
um
first can you high level can you tell
what this documentary is about yeah it
was early in
the syrian uprising and um
we returned to the syrian turkish border
with a syrian-american orthopedic
surgeon who was volunteering operating
on refugees as they float across the
border from syria to turkey
um and it was an attempt at the time
before a lot of films had come out about
the conflict
to um
really show again um
the effects of the war on civilians um
you've
heard me echo that sentiment multiple
times now but it
you know people knew there was there was
a a major conflict in syria but didn't
really understand the form that was
taken and the impact it was having and
so we we embedded into the at the time
it was the only clinic in turkey that
was sanctioned by the turkish government
to treat
syrian refugees
and so we filmed there with surgeons as
they operated on war victims
and we also went into syria into some of
the camps as well
so in this film
there's a man who crosses the border
every day to retrieve the wounded and
fair them safety and care and you also
mentioned about heroism in the united
states
um can you tell me about this man and
just people like him like what's the
heroic action
in some of these places that you've
visited
so in that instance you know i thought
of him as the turkish schindler
right because he was human being who
of his own volition volition no one was
paying him to do this
but he was spending
much of his time
he was just a local businessman
who really saw the need in the camps
right across the border 10k away
and and and he saw the medical need in
particular and how hard it was
to get people in desperate medical
conditions across the border where there
was a clinic just right across the
border but because of the security and
the layers of security
they couldn't get out by themselves
so he took it upon himself
as a turkish person
to build relationships with the turkish
guards which was relatively easy
and then he built relationships with
sort of the the guards in the no man's
land between the syrian guards and sort
of those who lived in the middle area
and then also with the syrian guards at
the camp and he would drive out there
daily and bring them food
right
talk them up and build relationships and
if so every day he would bring these
guards food and build relationships with
them and and what that meant was
eventually right he had this avenue of
access to and from the camps and so he
started using it and he would
drive this avenue of access
through the three layers of guards each
day
and then they would open the gates for
him because he had made himself
trustworthy in their eyes and he would
receive
the most desperate medical cases that
were coming from all over
northern syria right to receive medical
treatment and he would as you see in the
film he would ferry them into the back
of his car
right and then drive them to the
hospital where they would receive
operations
and then
he would bring them back if they wanted
after they'd healed and recovered back
to syria if they wanted to return at
post recovery and you know he didn't get
paid for that he was spending his own
money to do it
because he saw other human beings in
need
and it's like we were talking about
earlier
that's heroic right that's selfless
that's
that's aspirational for me right here's
here's someone who is spending their
time on the planet
doing something of value and good to
other human beings
i mean if you draw paralysis schindler i
feel like
the fascinating thing about
schindler is that
he's kind of a flawed human and is not
the kind of human that does these things
usually yeah but you just can't help it
yeah and that's like the basic humanity
despite
who you are the basic humanity shines
through i think the you know the whims
of war test people in those ways right
they ask of you things that you may not
even
know were going to be asked of you and
then it speaks to who who you are
fundamentally as a human being they
reveal
who you are as a human being just as you
said
you